sky news has verified this video that's
coming to us of the hospital that has
been completely destroyed ukraine's
president zelinski saying it is a
maternity hospital these are the
pictures as you can see uh complete
destruction there
president zielinski put out this tweet
in the last few minutes
saying direct strike of russian troops
at the maternity hospital people
children are under the wreckage atrocity
how much longer will the world be an
accomplice ignoring terror close the sky
right now stop the killings
you have power but you seem to be losing
humanity
no words
as to
casualties there but as you can see
utter destruction of that maternity
hospital in maripole we understand from
authorities in the city that over 1200
people have been killed so far there's a
big effort to get people out of the city
via
a humanitarian corridor that has been
agreed with russia
we understand that
at the moment
the agreement for that humanitarian
corridor is being upheld uh but as we
have
witnessed over the last few days uh
ceasefires have not been holding
humanitarian corridors not holding
either so it is a very fragile situation
in trying to evacuate the cities that
are currently being surrounded by
russian troops but this the scene
in maripol that southern city in ukraine
surrounded by russian troops that has
been completely destroyed it's a
maternity hospital no word yet on
casualties but we have just verified
this video that's come into us